AMIN: Hi, this is Amin
from the Glass team,
and I'm going to show
you how to create
voice driven GDK Glassware.
I'll show you the available APIs
and how to use each of them.
First, let's demonstrate
how to get directions
on Glass using Google Maps.
OK Glass, get directions
to San Francisco.
OK Glass, show route overview.
This Glassware uses
two voice APIs.
First, the voice
trigger API links
the get directions to voice
command to the Google Maps
Navigation activity.
Second, the contextual
voice menu API
defines a custom OK Glass
menu within this activity.
Let's dive deeper into
both of these APIs.
To launch your Glassware
from the voice main menu,
the first thing
you need to do is
to find a voice
trigger XML file.
This trigger specifies
which command
launches your Glassware,
what constraints
your activity
requires, as well as
whether your Glassware needs
open ended voice input.
Here, navigation trigger dot
XML uses the get directions
to command, requires
a network connection,
and needs open ended voice
input when launching.
Next, you'll need to refer
to this voice trigger
in the activity definition of
your Android manifest file.
Here is the Android manifest
for the Google Maps Navigation
Glassware.
You can see that the
navigation activity references
the navigation trigger
research we just
defined in its metadata section.
And that's it.
The next time you
install your APK,
you'll be able to launch your
Glassware from both the voice
and touch main menus
from the home screen.
Now I'll move on to
contextual voice menus.
Adding this menu share activity
straightforward, especially
if you're familiar with
how Android menus work.
The in-app OK Glass menu
is a window feature.
When you request
this window feature,
the Glass platform takes care
of enabling voice recognition
and showing the OK Glass
guard phrase on the screen.
When voice commands
are triggered,
the platform then calls
menu-specific methods
on your activity.
Just like standard
Android menus,
voice menus can also
be inflated from XML.
Here, navigation triggered
activity inflates the voice
menu XML in onCreatePanelMenu
and then handles voice commands
in onMenuItemSelected.
In addition to these
two Glass specific APIs,
GDK Glassware can also
use the RecognizerIntent
and SpeechRecognizer
APIs from the Android SDK
to collect open
ended voice input
from the user at any time.
With RecognizerIntent, you can
launch an activity in the Glass
platform, and that prompts
the user for open ended input.
This activity will look and
feel just like other open
ended UIs you've seen on Glass.
Here, main activity
launches a RecognizerIntent
and then processes
the recognized text
in onActivityResult.
If you want even more
control over voice input,
you can work directly
with the voice recognition
service via the
SpeechRecognizer API.
Your Glassware can define
a recognition listener
that will receive transcription
results in real time
while the user is speaking.
Here, main activity
creates a SpeechRecognizer
and implements some
of the callback
methods of RecognitionListener.
With these Android APIs allowing
fine grained control over voice
input along with the
Glass specific invocation
and contextual APIs, you can
create a compelling voice
driven experience to
power your GDK Glassware.
To find out more, make
sure to visit our website
and check out the Google
Developers YouTube
channel for more Glass videos.
Thank you for watching.